- In today's first round of
competition
we won't be doing
any signature styles.
Instead, we'll be making one of
J. Neilson's favorite weapons,
the European dagger.
I have actually
never made a dagger.
It's not something I
really wanted to do.
But I guess I'm doing it now.
WIL WILLIS:
Gentlemen your blades
must fall within the
following parameters.
The length of the blade must
fall between 10 and 12 inches.
The width of the blade at its
widest point must be at least 1
and 1/4 inches.
And you must have a double edged
blade with a ricasso that is
at least 3/4 of an inch long.
Your three hours starts now.
[music playing]
OK, so we've got 52
100 ball bearings.
We get chain saw, springs,
powdered steel, you name it,
everything out there can
be turned into a knife.
J. NEILSON: You could do it with
canister, upright, canoe, cube.
You could do a
laminate, layer it up,
do multiple different patterns.
There is the
possibility of thousands
of patterns and designs right
there on that one table.
DREW: I'm picking layered steel.
Because it's not
really tough to weld.
It's really easy to draw out.
And there's less of a
chance of it failing.
And I immediately start
to clean off the steel.
Because they've got
iron oxide on them.
It's really bad for a weld.
It's just evil for bladesmiths.
J. NEILSON: He's taking
that few extra minutes
to clean up that steel
is just a smart move.
[machinery running]
- Oh my God.
- What's up?
Can I get a Band-Aid?
I ran my thumb
across 36 grit belt.
And it ripped the
tip of my thumb
off and left it
flapping in the wind.
I'm off to a wonderful start.
Less than three minutes,
one of our contestants
is already bleeding
on the floor.
Yeah, that's a record.
That hurt.
David Baker, I feel
like I look like him today
with the vest and the tie.
Is Drew under
dressed for this?
No, no, I think Drew
styled it in actually.
DREW: I've got to
make this unique.
First thing is ladder pattern.
This won't do anything to the
functionality of the blade.
But it'll make my
blade look different.
J. NEILSON: Hey Drew.
- Hey.
Talk to me about what you're
doing with your patterning
here.
I don't think
it's deep enough.
That's my concern.
You've got a large
billet there still.
You didn't grind in very deep.
So if you go to try
and pattern that out,
your pattern is probably
not going to show up.
Yeah.
I might fold it over again
and get some more layers.
- That would be nice to see.
- And then--
You don't want to put
the work into that pattern
and have it disappear
once you forge it out.
I'm not a fool.
I've seen people lose
because they don't
take advice from the judges.
And I'm going to take
every single bit I can get.
[music playing]
I think it'll do.
J. NEILSON: We just had
Drew quench his blade.
DAVID BAKER: Quench early.
J. NEILSON: Yep.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Yep.
DAVID BAKER: Doesn't
hurt the blade.
You can grind a quenched blade.
Yep.
DREW: Grinding the
blade, especially
for a European dagger,
it's very important.
Because you've got to
get everything straight.
[grinder running]
I'm spending a ton
of time on this.
And I think it's time
well worth spent.
WIL WILLIS: All
right bladesmiths,
over the last three
hours, you've worked
on your European daggers.
Let's see if your
blades are up the specs.
Jason, you're up first.
DAVID BAKER: Well, first off,
your steel looks really good.
It's nice and clean.
Love to see a lot of
that material taken out,
maybe just a taper
put into this.
The ricasso is good.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
All right, Drew,
please present
your work to the judges.
J. NEILSON: You
know, Drew, watching
somebody work as well as
you did at half of my age
really impresses me.
Your steel looks good and tight.
But you do have quite a warp.
There's a few
different ways that you
can go ahead and fix that.
But overall a very nice job.
Thank you.
All right so, Drew,
first off, if you're
going to grind in a vest,
make sure it's a 100% cotton.
That thing could
go up in flames.
I really like the shape of this.
The fact that your
ricasso sets in.
You just have enough
ricasso there.
The lines are really clean.
I like the fact that that spine
goes all the way to the tip.
Nicely done.
I'm impressed by your work.
All right, Larry, you're up.
[music playing]
J. NEILSON: Well, Larry,
your steel looks pretty nice.
But we got a few
different issues here.
You're really thin down
here and thicker up here.
And you've got quite a
wave in your blade as well.
Big thing, where
is your ricasso?
I got behind the eight
ball, ran out of time.
All right, well,
that's a problem.
Yeah.
WIL WILLIS: Larry, your blade
was required to have a ricasso.
It doesn't.
That's grounds for immediate
dismissal from this forge.
The reason I have to
ask you to please leave.
[music playing]